[Musique]
toujours la même merde qui bravent tous
les interdits dans ce pays
les gauches à ce plan et les immigrés
qui ne ferait même pas un dixième du
quart de sa chez eux comme trump
il a dit du plomb
[Musique]
j'attends qu'une chose c'est que tous
ces gens crèvent
voilà en fait je n'ai plus envie de
sauver les gens je me dis que tous ces
gens doivent crever sa régénérera
l'espèce humaine et surtout la race
blanche
voilà un camp des gonzesses offre à des
wade et je m'en bats les six après elles
se font démonté la gueule buts et tout
ce que tu veux tu as voulu la couleur
maintenant faut que tu paye la redevance
là où nous les nationalistes racialiste
on doit être assez malin c'est en gros
laisser le combat intersectionnelle les
obligeait s'exterminer entre eux tu vois
ils vont déjà se séparer entre pro arabe
et pro juif
quand donc les féministes les lgbt et
les juifs les pneus qui sont pas
musulmans tous avons commencé à se
bouffer la gueule entre eux eh ben tu
manges tons pop corn tu regarde la télé
tu existes et armes et en fait quand ils
se sont bien affaibli tu as chez avec
les bêtes